其他人:给你一拳
Others: Give you a punch.
Jake:走走走走走走
Jake: Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Jake:就是这个
Jake: That's it.
Jake:哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: Hahaha, dumbass.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:你要穿
Jake: You have to穿...
Jake:你要穿模
Jake: You need to clip through the model.
Jake:你会穿模吗
Jake: Do you know how to clip through?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
其他人:我操这是他妈的这个沙雕
Others: Damn, this is such a damn idiot.
其他人:抖音上的短视频居然出现我眼前
Others: The TikTok short video actually appeared in front of me.
Lucia: 哈哈刚应该给你俩录一下的
Lucia: Haha, I should have recorded you two earlier.
其他人:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahahaha
Jake:都录了录着了录着了
Jake: It's all recorded, it's all recorded.
Jake:都有我第一视角就沙雕
Jake: I have it all from my first-person perspective, such an idiot.
Lucia: 也行我好
Lucia: That's fine, I'm good.
其他人:哈哈我好奇我们到时候音频要喘吗
Others: Haha, I'm curious if we'll need to edit the audio later.
Jake:传啊这个都传
Jake: Upload it, everything gets uploaded.
Lucia: 啊哈
Lucia: Ahaha
其他人:我总感觉这音频要自己
Others: I always feel like the audio will need editing.
其他人:这音频到时数据一清洗
Others: When the data is cleaned up later,
其他人:全洗完了
Others: it'll all be gone.
其他人:哈哈哈残缺不全
Others: Hahaha, incomplete.
Jake:缺点墨镜这倒是
Jake: Missing some sunglasses, that's true.
Jake:这些车牌号都得干掉
Jake: All these license plates need to be blurred out.
Jake:我靠哈哈好烦呐
Jake: Damn, it's so annoying.
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:就要干掉嘛
Jake: They need to be blurred out.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
其他人：你这时候应该往这走
Others: You should walk this way now.
其他人：就卡在这个地方
Others: Just get stuck in this spot.
其他人：哈哈哈卡在这
Others: Hahaha, get stuck here.
其他人：卡在卡进去
Others: Stuck, stuck in it.
Jake:你卡在两侧中间对
Jake: You're stuck between the two sides, right.
其他人：卡在我中间
Others: Stuck in the middle of me.
其他人：对
Others: Yeah.
其他人：哎你可以录我一段
Others: Hey, can you record a bit of me?
Jake:谢丽哈哈
Jake: Sherry, haha.
Jake:谢丽哈哈哈哈哈哈一路抖音吗
Jake: Sherry, hahaha, all the way TikTok, huh?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 从未觉得这么平凡的一条路
Lucia: Never thought such an ordinary road
Lucia: 能有这么多的危险
Lucia: Could have so many dangers
Lucia: 平凡吗不平凡吗
Lucia: Ordinary? Not ordinary?
Lucia: 也走过人山人海
Lucia: I've also walked through crowded places
Lucia: 忘了哈哈哈
Lucia: I forgot, hahaha
Lucia: 我ICOD储存空间已满
Lucia: My ICOD storage is full
Lucia: happy
Lucia: Happy
Lucia: birthday
Lucia: Birthday
Jake:回头率不低啊
Jake: Getting a lot of attention, huh?
Jake:走我们去我们去给他们祝贺一下
Jake: Let's go, let's go congratulate them
Lucia: 哈哈哈你这什么社交恐怖分子吗
Lucia: Hahaha, are you some kind of social terrorist?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈这几个像伪装起来
Jake: Haha, these guys look like they're in disguise
Jake:哈比夫人哈哈哈跟缩油似的哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, Mrs. Hobbit, hahaha, looks like she's shrinking, hahaha
其他人:（歌词）哒哒哒我们相亲又相爱
Others: (Lyrics) Da da da, we are so close and loving
Lucia: 我去
Lucia: Oh my
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:我错了哈哈哈哈
Jake: I was wrong, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊哈哈过了吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is it over?
Jake:没有没有他错了
Jake: No, no, he was wrong
Jake:对了对了对了哈哈
Jake: Right, right, right, haha
Lucia: 行大家都是社交恐怖分子是吧
Lucia: Okay, everyone's a social terrorist, right?
Jake:对我我我们一排爱人
Jake: Yeah, we, we, we are all lovers
Lucia: 真的哈哈
Lucia: Really, haha
Lucia: 我们可爱人
Lucia: We are lovely
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈你觉得我信吗哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, do you think I believe that, haha
Lucia: 月亮月亮
Lucia: Moon, moon
Jake:月亮
Jake: Moon
Jake:耶唱歌呢
Jake: Hey, singing
Jake:对今儿周末应该挺多是闲人
Jake: Yeah, it's the weekend, should be a lot of people with free time
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈那问题也不大是不是
Jake: Hahaha, that's not a big deal, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 这么大个人了
Lucia: Such a big person
Lucia: 反正不会丢
Lucia: Won't get lost anyway
Jake:哈哈哈什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what is that?
Jake:记一下记一下记一下记一下记一下
Jake: Write it down, write it down, write it down, write it down, write it down
Jake:哈哈秀秀这单你自己解
Jake: Haha, Shure, you handle this one yourself.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 左拐啊左拐
Lucia: Turn left, turn left.
Lucia: 对着了吧
Lucia: Got it, right?
Jake:对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: OK
其他人:你们要剪就都保留走
Others: If you want to edit, keep everything.
其他人:这一段你说呗
Others: You talk about this part.
Jake:他收音挺好的
Jake: The audio is pretty good.
Jake:呵呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:因为他就在你脸上了
Jake: Because it's right in your face.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:12:21危险言论
Others: 12:21 dangerous speech
Lucia: 我正在迅速复盘
Lucia: I'm quickly reviewing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈危险言论
Jake: Hahaha, dangerous speech.
Lucia: 我有没有说过什么
Lucia: Did I say something...
Lucia: 哈哈不适合的我忘记了
Lucia: Haha, inappropriate? I forgot.
Jake:不管不管
Jake: Never mind, never mind.
Jake:到时候看吧
Jake: We'll see later.
Jake:对慢慢削吧
Jake: Yeah, take it slow.
Jake:擅长生产无用数据哈哈哈
Jake: Skilled at producing useless data, hahaha.
Jake:又有小车
Jake: Another small car.
Jake:准备FFF FF
Jake: Get ready, FFF, FFF.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Jake:先拿一下站嘴边
Jake: First, stand close.
Jake:然后会停
Jake: Then it will stop.
Jake:就是我们的姐姐
Jake: It's our sister.
Jake:哈喽这是
Jake: Hello, this is...
Jake:这是带我们的
Jake: She's leading us.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:你这个动作不对
Others: Your move is wrong.
Alice:我要知道
Alice: I need to know.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 你动作太保守了
Lucia: Your move is too conservative.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 23456确实哈
Lucia: 23456, indeed.
Jake:欢庆春节
Jake: Celebrating the Spring Festival.
其他人：昨天晚上睡觉动了吗
Others: Did you move while sleeping last night?
Jake:我不知道OK
Jake: I don't know, OK.
Jake:哈哈哈你不会我
Jake: Hahaha, you won't believe me
Jake:哈哈哈我真不知道
Jake: Hahaha, I really don't know
Jake:哈哈哈我应该知道什么吧
Jake: Hahaha, I should know something, right?
其他人:因为我觉得我睡得很踏实啊
Others: Because I feel I sleep really well
Jake:你再你再挤一条
Jake: Squeeze out another one
Jake:你再挤一条
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈你能不能不让学术
Jake: Hahaha, can you stop making it academic
Jake:这些做学术的人做这东西
Jake: These academics doing this stuff
Jake:有但是好像没有你说的这些东西
Jake: There is, but not what you're talking about
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
其他人:他妈的7.08-09全删完
Others: Damn, 7.08-09 all deleted
Lucia: 救命
Lucia: Help
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 不要
Lucia: No
Lucia: 一个个我都不想出现在这个画符里了
Lucia: I don't want to appear in this footage at all
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Jake:唱点能播的
Jake: Sing something that can be broadcasted
Jake:哈哈完了哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, it's over, haha
Jake:没有
Jake: No
Jake:曲库里面没有
Jake: It's not in the song library
Jake:不存在的
Jake: Doesn't exist
其他人:那你先唱吧我给你接着唱
Others: Then you sing first, I'll follow
其他人:你不仅要顶你一个人的眼镜
Others: You have to hold your glasses
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 工作室可能是的
Lucia: The studio maybe
Jake:里面有人
Jake: There's someone inside
Jake:有好几个人
Jake: Quite a few people
Jake:呵嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:好这翻译的
Jake: Alright, the translation
Lucia: 牛啊
Lucia: Impressive
Jake:这很难很难信
Jake: This is hard to believe
Jake:很难不信达雅哈哈哈
Jake: It's hard not to believe Daya haha
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
Jake:如意看见没
Jake: Look, do you see it?
Jake:吉祥
Jake: Auspicious
Jake:啊吉祥如意
Jake: Ah, prosperity and good luck
其他人:follow your heart
Others: Follow your heart
Lucia: 是这边吧
Lucia: Is it this way?
其他人:我怎么感觉
Others: I feel like
其他人:都要走到那个什么卫生间了
Others: We're almost at the restroom
Jake:就是那哦
Jake: It's right there
Lucia: 哎卫生站是这样走的吗
Lucia: Hey, is the health station this way?
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay
Jake:哎锦州巷子里要
Jake: Hey, in Jinzhou alley, you need to
Lucia: 是晚上所以
Lucia: It's night, so
Lucia: 哈哈哈吓了一天
Lucia: Haha, scared all day
其他人：连自己来的地方都不知道
Others: Don't even know where you came from
Jake:哈哈哈整点串吧
Jake: Haha, let's get some skewers
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:要不带点串回去吧要不
Jake: How about we take some skewers back?
Lucia: 因为昨天那会已经是晚上了
Lucia: Because yesterday it was already night
Lucia: 现在这个天色又不认识了
Lucia: Now with this lighting, I don't recognize it
Jake:好香哦
Jake: Smells so good
Jake:你昨天直接走过来也挺挺远我感觉
Jake: You walked quite a distance yesterday, I feel
其他人:我草我也想吃
Others: Damn, I want to eat too
Lucia: 我总觉得
Lucia: I always feel
Lucia: 我昨天走的时候好像没这么远
Lucia: It didn't seem this far when I walked yesterday
Jake:主要旁边没别人
Jake: Mainly because there's no one else around
Lucia: 哈哈不是哈哈哈不是真不是
Lucia: Haha, no, really, no
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
其他人:你让我们时间变得很欢乐
Others: You make our time so joyful
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah
其他人:欢乐的时光对
Others: Happy times, yeah
Lucia: 他这小路挺多的
Lucia: There are so many small paths
Lucia: 可能昨天走的不是同一个小路
Lucia: Maybe I didn't take the same path yesterday
Jake:就消耗比较大是吧
Jake: So, you consumed a lot, right?
Jake:对有点累
Jake: Yeah, a bit tired
其他人：买个彩票
Others: Buy a lottery ticket
其他人：要草就买个彩票走走走
Others: Yeah, let's buy a lottery ticket, let's go
Jake:延吉冷面
Jake: Yanji cold noodles
Jake:啊买彩票啊
Jake: Ah, a lottery ticket
Jake:真买彩票
Jake: Really buying one?
其他人:真买
Others: Really buying
Jake:看看看你刮彩票买买买
Jake: Look, look, you keep buying scratch tickets.
其他人:5050 来就来
Others: 50/50, let's go.
其他人:大的怎么这么少报销呢
Others: Why is the big one so rarely reimbursed?
Jake:怎么这么
Jake: Why is it so...
其他人:报销不报啊
Others: Aren't you reimbursing it?
Jake:报销刮彩票那
Jake: Reimburse for scratch tickets?
Jake:那你刮出来算啥啊
Jake: What if you win?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人:这样吧你给我报
Others: How about this, you reimburse me.
其他人:50我还刮
Others: I'll keep scratching.
其他人:刮出来钱都是你的
Others: If I win, the money's yours.
其他人:哈哈哈啊
Others: Hahaha
Jake:这么回事
Jake: What's going on?
其他人:我靠你好老
Others: Damn, you're old.
其他人:厉害啊哈
Others: Impressive, haha.
其他人：所有女朋友生日连起来
Others: All your girlfriends' birthdays combined.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人:呵这是能算出来吗
Others: Can you even figure that out?
Jake:你别看你看什么菜单啊
Jake: Don't look, what are you looking at the menu for?
Jake:你看那边篮球来一个
Jake: Look over there, basketball coming up.
其他人：我也想刮了
Others: I want to scratch too.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
其他人：5倍
Others: Five times!
Jake:牛批
Jake: Awesome.
其他人：别动
Others: Don't move.
其他人：给我来一个老板
Others: Give me one, boss.
其他人:那你戴眼镜
Others: Why are you wearing glasses?
Jake:不用不用不用
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake:不不不这么搞这么搞
Jake: No, no, not like that.
其他人:但刮彩票可以很解压
Others: But scratching tickets is stress-relieving.
其他人:如果刮出来就更解压
Others: If you win, it's even more stress-relieving.
其他人:来吧
Others: Come on.
其他人:刮出来了
Others: I won!
其他人:刮出来就吸了来
Others: If you win, you're hooked.
其他人:最高奖金80万呢
Others: The top prize is 800,000.
其他人：哈喽
Others: Hello.
Lucia: 让我看看这个的玩法
Lucia: Let me see how to play this one.
其他人:就刮带这个带这个符号的
Others: Just scratch the ones with this symbol.
其他人:哦这个符号是刮不出来的
Others: Oh, this symbol can't be scratched.
其他人:我觉得还有一个我的号码
Others: I think there's another one with my number.
其他人:对你先把你的号码刮出来
Others: Yeah, scratch off your number first.
其他人:中奖号码你的号码刮出来
Others: Winning number, scratch off your number.
其他人:嗯那我也刮这个
Others: Hmm, then I'll scratch this one too.
其他人:快不行
Others: Hurry, can't take it.
其他人：我要忍住
Others: I have to hold back.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：完了
Others: Done for.
其他人：不你这是多少
Others: No, how much is this?
Jake:哎 50的
Jake: Hey, it's 50.
Jake:你这为什么更牛逼
Jake: Why is yours even better?
其他人:来就来大的
Others: Go big or go home.
其他人:你中了吗
Others: Did you win?
Jake:他有几个铲子啊
Jake: How many shovels does he have?
Jake:就一个铲子 34
Jake: Just one shovel, 34.
其他人:我这是金铲子
Others: Mine's a golden shovel.
Jake:呵呵呵不太像
Jake: Haha, doesn't look like it.
其他人:他这个没中
Others: His didn't win.
其他人:记好回本了回本了
Others: Remember, we broke even, broke even.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What does it mean?
Jake:啥意思
其他人:他回本了
Others: He broke even.
Jake:哦对了21哎
Jake: Oh right, 21, hey.
Jake:哎呦这贵的就是快刮的
Jake: Wow, the expensive ones scratch faster.
其他人: 哦这些这些都能直接换钱
Others: Oh, these, these can all be exchanged for cash.
Jake:对啥意思
Jake: Yeah, what does it mean?
其他人:只要刮出来钱就是钱
Others: As long as you scratch money, it's money.
Jake:这刮这么多钱啊
Jake: We scratched so much money?
其他人:就接就是得有彩才行
Others: Yeah, just need a prize to count.
Jake:哦那给你写个数字干嘛呀
Jake: Oh, then why write a number for you?
其他人:如果有彩就是下面的钱
Others: If there's a prize, it's the amount below.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake:是啥意思
Jake: What does it mean?
其他人:就是啥也没有
Others: It means nothing.
其他人:就是鸡的意思
Others: It just means chicken.
Jake:哈哈哈哦
Jake: Haha, oh.
Jake:啊你这多少钱呢
Jake: Ah, how much is yours?
其他人：你这多少钱的
Others: How much is yours?
Jake:也是20
Jake: Also 20.
Lucia: 也是20
Lucia: Also 20.
其他人:寄了我怎么感觉寄了
Others: I feel like it's sent.
Jake:你这50块钱怎么一
Jake: How come your 50 bucks...
Jake:毛都没有
Jake: ...didn't even get a hair?
其他人:50块钱寄了
Others: 50 bucks, sent.
Jake:好可以捐到50是吧
Jake: Alright, we can donate up to 50, right?
Jake:福利了我已经逐渐忍住捐了
Jake: Lucky me, I gradually held back and donated.
其他人: 我已经逐渐忍住捐了50
Others: I gradually held back and donated 50.
其他人：啊 80万
Others: Ah, 800,000.
Jake:啊这要看啥呀
Jake: Ah, what are we looking at?
其他人:但我觉得能刮到写80万的也很不容易
Others: But I think it's really hard to scratch off 800,000.
其他人:已经开始激动了
Others: Already getting excited.
其他人:不是主要是我这一顿隐形眼睛
Others: No, the main thing is my contact lenses...
其他人:哦哦哦这样看着直接刮过了
Others: Oh oh oh, just scratch it directly.
Jake:哦你你这个80万你特地不刮是吧
Jake: Oh, you're deliberately not scratching off the 800,000, right?
Jake:就是你最后再
Jake: You're saving it for last.
Jake:呵呵呵你最后等着
Jake: Hehe, you're waiting for the last moment.
Jake:十十是没有
Jake: Ten, there's no ten.
其他人:哇这中奖率好低啊
Others: Wow, the winning rate is so low.
Jake:30哎
Jake: 30, hey.
Jake:没7 那是什么呀
Jake: No seven. What's that?
其他人:最上面那个
Others: The one on top.
其他人:万一80万呢
Others: What if it's 800,000?
Jake:万一就50中呢
Jake: What if it's just 50?
Jake:14 那80万
Jake: 14, that 800,000...
Jake:80万看看
Jake: 800,000, let's see.
Jake:卧槽我靠
Jake: Damn, almost.
其他人:哇塞差一点
Others: Wow, so close.
Jake:差一点差一点
Jake: So close, so close.
Jake:哎差点憋出一个哎
Jake: Almost held back one, hey.
其他人：快点搞我也我也有点想法
Others: Hurry up, I also have an idea.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈老板来一张这个啊
Jake: Hahaha, boss, give me one of these.
其他人：老板给我来一张这个20的
Others: Boss, give me one of these 20s.
Jake:哈哈哈老板还有多少张
Jake: Hahaha, boss, how many are left?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:哈哈 80万是吧
Jake: Haha, 800,000, right?
其他人:哎好久不刮了
Others: Haven't scratched in a while.
其他人:上一次刮可能还是两年之前
Others: Last time I scratched one was probably two years ago.
其他人:没了
Others: That's it.
Lucia: 哎呀人均一个
Lucia: Oh, everyone gets one.
Lucia: 那我也买一张吧
Lucia: Then I'll buy one too.
Jake:哈哈哈但我压力很大了哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, but I'm really stressed out now, haha.
Lucia: 我也要一张20的嗯
Lucia: I'll take a 20 one too, mm.
Jake:这钱上哪领啊
Jake: Where do we claim this money?
Jake:直接直接给是吧哦
Jake: Just give it directly, right? Oh.
Lucia: 我扫您吗
Lucia: Should I scan you?
Lucia: 嗯我以为
Lucia: Mm, I thought...
其他人:看日记没有
Others: Did you check the diary?
Lucia: 微信支付
Lucia: WeChat Pay.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
其他人:没有
Others: No.
其他人:哇那很厉害
Others: Wow, that's impressive.
其他人:捐了20福利
Others: Donated 20 to welfare.
Jake:捐20
Jake: Donated 20.
Jake:好嘞福利好
Jake: Alright, welfare is good.
Jake:福利福利
Jake: Welfare, welfare.
其他人:他中奖率也太低
Others: His winning rate is so low.
其他人:我之前看过有人刮一本
Others: I saw someone scratch a whole book before.
其他人:刮一本算那个算那个钱
Others: Scratching a whole book counts as that, counts as that money.
Lucia: 这是我的
Lucia: This is mine.
其他人:我操又有素材了啊
Others: Oh my, more material again.
Lucia: 哈哈大家既然都买了我也跟一张
Lucia: Haha, since everyone is buying, I'll get one too.
Jake:先看下哪
Jake: Let's see first.
Jake:一个吧那我很难不买了
Jake: One, then it's hard for me not to buy.
其他人:那你跟一个
Others: Then you get one too.
Jake:那我更个20的
Jake: I'll get a 20 one.
其他人:跟个20
Others: Get a 20 one.
Jake:这这红的红的和蓝色有什么差别吗
Jake: What's the difference between the red and blue ones?
Jake:没有差别
Jake: No difference.
Lucia: 我觉得我都好久没玩过这个了
Lucia: I feel like I haven't played this in so long.
其他人：哎你这书都很近啊
Others: Hey, your book is very close.
Lucia: 哈哈近有什么用呢
Lucia: Haha, what's the use of being close?
其他人：像刚刚那个
Others: Like just now.
其他人：刚刚那个80万其实也很近对吧哈哈哈
Others: Just now that 800,000 was actually very close, right? Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎近有什么用呢
Lucia: Hey, what's the use of being close?
其他人:差点差点差点差点就可以光荣的从这里离开了
Others: Almost, almost, almost, almost could have left here gloriously.
Jake:整个20了吧
Jake: Get a 20 one.
其他人:哎他中奖率好
Others: Hey, his winning rate is good.
Lucia: 是感觉小时候的
Lucia: It feels like when we were kids.
Lucia: 都比这个中奖率能高一点
Lucia: The winning rate was higher back then.
其他人:我们连买了123四五张
Others: We bought like four or five tickets in a row.
其他人:对啊这概率有点低是吧哈哈好气
Others: Yeah, the odds are a bit low, right? Haha, so frustrating.
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right?
Jake:来来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: Here it comes, here it comes, here it comes, here it comes.
Lucia: 哈哈好气
Lucia: Haha, so frustrating.
Lucia: 中国有句古话叫做
Lucia: There's an old Chinese saying that goes
Jake:屎屎哈哈哈
Jake: Crap, crap, hahaha.
Lucia: 屎屎屎
Lucia: Crap, crap, crap.
Jake:没
Jake: Nope.
Jake:没有
Jake: Nothing.
其他人:哎哦没有
Others: Oh, nothing.
Jake:没有
Jake: Nothing.
Jake:哎中了30
Jake: Hey, won 30.
Jake:哎呦哎呦哎呦卖10块
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, sell it for 10 bucks.
Jake:哎呦来看看
Jake: Hey, let's take a look.
Jake:招招18哎
Jake: Look, 18.
Jake:还是23是吧
Jake: Or is it 23, right?
Jake:是2327
Jake: It's 2327.
其他人:很难中两个
Others: It's hard to win two.
其他人:很难中两好
Others: It's hard to win two good ones.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Okay then.
其他人:还刮吗
Others: Want to scratch more?
Jake:不刮了不刮了
Jake: No more scratching, no more.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Jake:见好见好就收
Jake: Quit while you're ahead.
Jake:见好就收
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph.
其他人:投资回报率也太低了
Others: The return on investment is too low.
Jake:你这是
Jake: You mean
Lucia: 你想考什么时候关门吗
Lucia: Do you want to know when it closes?
Jake:现在就去吧
Jake: Let's go now then.
Jake:就是就在跑隔壁
Jake: It's just next door.
Jake:早知道我们是7点多到
Jake: If we had known, we would have come at 7.
Jake:有30
Jake: Got 30.
Jake:就一个30
Jake: Just one 30.
Jake:就这头
Jake: That's it.
其他人:哦这个这个这个
Others: Oh, this, this, this.
其他人:你是要相信运气的
Others: You need to believe in luck.
Jake:谢可以在这继续走吧
Jake: Can we continue walking here?
其他人:有些人就是一直买一个号
Others: Some people always buy the same number.
其他人:然后可能突然有一天没买就真的中
Others: Then suddenly, one day they don't buy it, and they win.
Jake:就那排队的
Jake: The one in line.
Jake:他就是在菜鸟驿站没有取
Jake: He didn't pick it up at the rookie station.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Right?
Jake:还是说还有别的地
Jake: Or is it somewhere else?
Lucia: 呃还有别的地还有别的地
Lucia: Uh, it's somewhere else, somewhere else.
Jake:别的地
Jake: Somewhere else?
Lucia: 星辰
Lucia: Xingchen.
Lucia: 有一个星辰分布还是啥
Lucia: There's a Xingchen distribution or something.
Lucia: 呃我不是京东
Lucia: Uh, not JD.
Lucia: 那个雨轩是京东
Lucia: That Yuxuan is JD.
Lucia: 哎啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 不是锦东
Lucia: Not Jindong.
Lucia: 那应该还能去到
Lucia: It should still be reachable.
Jake:那你在这先排
Jake: Then you line up here first.
Jake:我到前面看看去
Jake: I'll go check ahead.
Jake:前面可能还有一个口
Jake: There might be another entrance ahead.
Lucia: 好啊
Lucia: Sure.
Jake:还有一个
Jake: Another one.
其他人：你等会啊
Others: Wait a minute.
其他人：我我给他看看
Others: I'll take a look for him.
Lucia: 在这边吗
Lucia: Is it here?
其他人：也是
Others: Yes.
其他人：楼下
Others: Downstairs.
其他人：8182您看有吗
Others: 8182, do you see it?
其他人：哥 94不是9184
Others: Bro, it's 94, not 9184.
其他人：手机尾号9184 对
Others: The last four digits of the phone number, 9184, right.
其他人：叫什么知道吗
Others: Do you know the name?
其他人：叫什么
Others: What's the name?
其他人：叫
Others: Name?
其他人： 张梦瑶姓张
Others: Zhang Mengyao, surname Zhang.
Lucia: 我觉得好像有蚊子
Lucia: I think there are mosquitoes.
Lucia: 呃你好那个626001
Lucia: Uh, hello, that 626001.
其他人：书店人叫什么
Others: What's the name of the bookstore person?
Lucia: 呃朱先生
Lucia: Uh, Mr. Zhu.
Lucia: 然后还有还有那个846003
Lucia: And then there's also that 846003.
Lucia: 啊这是美文纸
Lucia: Ah, this is the beautiful paper
Lucia: 还有一个四四6003
Lucia: And there's also a 44-6003
其他人：四四多少 6003
Others: 44 what? 6003
其他人： 6003
Others: 6003
其他人：7010啊 70107010
Others: 7010, ah 7010-7010
Lucia: 然后我这有个申通
Lucia: And then I have a Shentong here
Lucia: 他显示的是已签收
Lucia: It shows as delivered
Lucia: 但是我觉得还是在驿站
Lucia: But I think it's still at the station
Lucia: 因为他没有给我送货上门
Lucia: Because they didn't deliver it to my door
Lucia: 您看一眼是在这嗯
Lucia: Could you take a look, is it here?
Lucia: 这是哪个东西
Lucia: Which item is this?
Lucia: 我都忘了
Lucia: I forgot
其他人：查全号呢这个
Others: Check the full number on this one
其他人：8128
Others: 8128
其他人：8128 6113
Others: 8128-6113
其他人：下回下回再给你打电话
Others: Next time, next time we'll call you
其他人：送到上面
Others: Deliver it up there
其他人：你问他你咋不给我送呢
Others: You ask them why they didn't deliver it
Lucia: 行行好嘞
Lucia: Okay, okay
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢
Lucia: Haha, thanks
Lucia: 就是他应该给我送货上门啊
Lucia: They should deliver it to my door
Lucia: 他显示我签收
Lucia: It shows I signed for it
Lucia: 您看一眼
Lucia: Take a look
Lucia: 这个是在这不
Lucia: Is it here or not
Lucia: 还是在
Lucia: Still at
其他人：不是这不是
Others: No, it's not
Lucia: 那边的
Lucia: Over there
Lucia: 哎行行
Lucia: Okay, okay
Lucia: 他说这个新城分布
Lucia: They said it's at the new city distribution
Lucia: 这个是在那边
Lucia: It's over there
Lucia: 您先看看你的
Lucia: You check yours first
Lucia: 啊咳啊
Lucia: Ah, cough, ah
Lucia: Excuse me
Katrina: 1715-7601这是7088
Katrina: 1715-7601, this is 7088
其他人： 15-7还是多少
Others: 15-7, what was it?
Katrina: 姓杨啊  60116零11
Katrina: Surname Yang, 60116
Katrina: 你还有吗
Katrina: Do you have any more?
Lucia: 那我我今天就差另外的那个了
Lucia: I'm just missing that other one today
Lucia: 其实还有俩还没到我也是
Lucia: Actually, there are two more that haven't arrived
Lucia: 不过这俩都是小
Lucia: But both are small items
Lucia: 东西明天应该能到
Lucia: The stuff should arrive tomorrow.
Katrina: 1-1六零零六零零六
Katrina: 1-1 six zero zero six zero zero six.
Katrina: 幺杠幺六零零六
Katrina: One-dash-one six zero zero six.
Lucia: 啊可爱
Lucia: Ah, cute.
其他人：你那多少
Others: How much is yours?
Katrina: 8杠对
Katrina: Eight-dash right.
Katrina: 8-48这不是我们这的吧
Katrina: Eight-dash-forty-eight, this isn't ours, right?
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Lucia: 菜鸟驿站
Lucia: Cainiao Station.
Lucia: 31号房是哪啊
Lucia: Where is room 31?
其他人：31号房在哪啊我都不知道
Others: Where is room 31? I have no idea.
其他人：你点开看看地址在哪吧
Others: Why don't you open it and check the address?
其他人： 31号房在哪
Others: Where is room 31?
Katrina: 快递盒
Katrina: A courier box.
Lucia: 应该可以扔
Lucia: It should be okay to throw away.
Lucia: 这会有一些人回收吧估计
Lucia: Someone might come to recycle it, I guess.
Lucia: 我好了我就差那个
Lucia: I'm ready, I just need that.
Lucia: 就星辰分部
Lucia: Just the Starry Division.
Lucia: 啊小心刚那掉哪去了哦
Lucia: Ah, careful, where did that drop? Oh.
Lucia: 在这里面
Lucia: It's in here.
Lucia: 哎呀麻烦死了
Lucia: Oh, such a hassle.
Lucia: 我觉得他们应该经经
Lucia: I think they should have done
Lucia: 就是做过那个压各种压力测试吧
Lucia: various pressure tests on it, right?
Lucia: 啊啊明天还找管家8807
Lucia: Ah, we still need to find the manager 8807 tomorrow.
Katrina: 明天还找管家
Katrina: We still need to find the manager tomorrow.
其他人：8807
Others: 8807.
Lucia: 关键他取的压根就不全烦死了
Lucia: The key is he never gets everything, it's so annoying.
Lucia: 哎他们去哪了
Lucia: Ah, where did they go?
Katrina: 因为我们宿舍离菜鸟驿站特别远
Katrina: Because our dorm is really far from the Cainiao Station.
Lucia: 这个地方是新城分布
Lucia: This place is the New City branch.
Lucia: 小溪新溪
Lucia: Xiaoxi, Xinxing.
Lucia: 原百世
Lucia: Former Best Logistics.
Lucia: 养老公寓对面院内
Lucia: Inside the courtyard opposite the retirement home.
Lucia: 什么狗屁
Lucia: What nonsense.
Lucia: 这里有蚊子我靠
Lucia: There are mosquitoes here, damn.
Lucia: 邻里来取驿站
Lucia: Neighborly Pickup Station.
Lucia: 不知道他这什么地方
Lucia: I don't know what place this is.
Katrina: 百事的百事的
Katrina: Best Logistics, Best Logistics.
Lucia: 是我的应该应该是我的
Lucia: It's mine, it should be mine.
Lucia: 呃是那个
Lucia: Uh, it's that.
Lucia: 稍等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on a second.
Lucia: 呃是行行
Lucia: Uh, okay, okay.
Lucia: 好嘞好嘞您稍等一下
Lucia: Alright, alright, please wait a moment.
Lucia: 我发给修硕是吧看一下
Lucia: I'll send it to Shure, right? Take a look.
Lucia: 912563应该是这个
Lucia: 912563, it should be this one.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 是中通
Lucia: It's Zhongtong.
Lucia: 咱要不要去找他们他们是从哪出去的
Lucia: Should we go find them? Where did they go?
Katrina: 不知道主要是我现在什么隐形啊
Katrina: I don't know, the thing is, I'm invisible right now.
Lucia: 你只带了一个隐形
Lucia: You only brought one contact lens?
Katrina: 对好奇怪
Katrina: Yeah, it's so weird.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 带一个隐形的话会就是既清楚又模糊
Lucia: Wearing just one contact lens makes things both clear and blurry.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 语音通话一下问问他们在哪
Lucia: Let's call them and ask where they are.
Katrina: 是吧
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 对咱们刚从那边来的
Lucia: Yeah, we just came from over there.
Katrina: 慢慢走过去
Katrina: Let's walk over slowly.
Lucia: 截图
Lucia: Screenshot.
Lucia: 等一下修硕
Lucia: Wait a second, Shure.
Lucia: 我给他截个图
Lucia: I'll take a screenshot for him.
Katrina: 明天给你看看我装饰的房间
Katrina: I'll show you the room I decorated tomorrow.
Lucia: 我网卡了靠
Lucia: My internet is lagging, damn.
Lucia: 不过应该是没有别的了
Lucia: But there shouldn't be anything else.
Lucia: 没有了就这个
Lucia: That's it, just this.
Lucia: 谢谢你们是在哪边
Lucia: Thank you, where are you?
Lucia: 是我和雨轩过去
Lucia: Is it me and Yuxuan going over?
Lucia: 还是你们一会还从这条路回来
Lucia: Or are you guys coming back this way later?
Lucia: 嗯嗯
Lucia: Uh-huh.
Lucia: 我买这渔网他说给我送土丁了
Lucia: I bought this fishing net, and he said he'd send me some small parts.
Lucia: 一会让我看看他送没送
Lucia: Let me check if he sent them.
Lucia: 怎么感觉摸着没有呢
Lucia: Why does it feel like they're not there?
Lucia: 啊不弄墙就是
Lucia: Oh, not on the wall, it's fine.
Lucia: 我有一我买了一个那种照片墙啊对
Lucia: I bought a photo wall, yeah.
Katrina: 哦哦就行
Katrina: Oh, that's fine.
Lucia: 但是就他肯定还得往墙上固定一下
Lucia: But it definitely needs to be fixed on the wall.
Lucia: 因为这个东西比照片墙要大
Lucia: Because this thing is bigger than a photo wall.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 所以我打算用美纹纸贴一下
Lucia: So I'm planning to use some masking tape.
Katrina: 我之前好像也看见过这种
Katrina: I think I've seen something like that before.
Katrina: 什么在墙上的照片墙
Katrina: What's that photo wall on the wall?
Lucia: 照片墙啊对
Lucia: Oh, it's a photo wall.
Lucia: 因为我其实一直想给我自己的卧室
Lucia: Because I've always wanted to make one for my bedroom.
Lucia: 也弄一个
Lucia: Make one too.
Lucia: 照片墙哈哈喜欢直接
Lucia: A photo wall, haha, I love it.
Katrina: 到时候咱直接无痛迁移
Katrina: We'll just move it painlessly when the time comes.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 等到把这些都拆下来
Lucia: Once we take all these down,
Lucia: 我就把家里能用的给他带走
Lucia: I'll take whatever I can use from home.
Lucia: 哈哈他们怎么说
Lucia: Haha, what do they say?
Katrina: 他们怎么说
Katrina: What do they say?
Lucia: 看一眼好像还没回复
Lucia: Let me check, seems like they haven't replied yet.
Lucia: 也可能是我网不太好
Lucia: Maybe my internet is bad.
Lucia: 不知发出去没
Lucia: Not sure if it sent.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 我已经被咬了
Lucia: I've already been bitten.
Katrina: 我也是怎么说我们往那走
Katrina: Me too. So, where should we go?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 他还没回我
Lucia: He hasn't replied yet.
Lucia: 要不给他打个电话
Lucia: Should I give him a call?
Lucia: 语音通话
Lucia: Voice call.
Lucia: 不会是他网不好吧哈哈
Lucia: Could it be his internet that's bad? Haha.
Lucia: 可能他们一会也就过来了
Lucia: Maybe they'll come over soon.
Lucia: 那可能他们就过来了
Lucia: Maybe they're on their way now.
其他人：谁弄的谁弄的
Others: Who did it, who did it?
其他人：我找着这个小孩查监控去
Others: I'm going to find this kid and check the surveillance.
其他人：上上里边走
Others: Let's go inside.
其他人：查监控
Others: Check the surveillance.
Lucia: 怎么一个个都不接电话呀
Lucia: Why is no one answering the phone?
Lucia: 估计一会就回来了吧
Lucia: I guess they'll be back soon.
Katrina: 走吧我们往回走吧
Katrina: Let's go back.
Lucia: 他们在哪个方向呢
Lucia: Which direction are they in?
Lucia: 你们是在哪个方向呀
Lucia: Which direction are you guys in?
Lucia: 我们是直接往回走还是怎么样呀
Lucia: Should we head back directly or what?
Lucia: 我觉得有可
Lucia: I think there might be...
Lucia: 嗯刚想说有可能是我网不好
Lucia: Hmm, I was just saying maybe my internet is bad.
Lucia: 然后转了一下圈又发出去了
Lucia: Then it spun around and sent it out.
Lucia: 那他们应该能收到
Lucia: They should receive it.
Lucia: 他们网不好
Lucia: Their internet is bad.
Katrina: 他们被拐到哪里去了
Katrina: Where have they been taken?
Lucia: 好可怕哈哈
Lucia: That's so scary, haha.
Katrina: 好冷啊晚上要回家衣服
Katrina: It's so cold, I need to go home and get some clothes.
Lucia: 我也晚上是有点冷
Lucia: Yeah, it's a bit chilly at night.
Lucia: 我昨天出去的时候也觉得有点冷
Lucia: I felt a bit cold when I went out yesterday too.
Katrina: 嗯白天好热
Katrina: Yeah, it's so hot during the day.
Lucia: 哎那个是他们吗
Lucia: Hey, is that them?
Lucia: 有好几个人
Lucia: There's a bunch of people.
Lucia: 那有好几个人是他们吗
Lucia: Is that them over there, with a bunch of people?
Lucia: 是不是人数比他们要多一些好像
Lucia: Are there more people than they should have?
Lucia: 感觉不是
Lucia: Feels like it's not them.
Lucia: 应该是别人
Lucia: Probably someone else.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 啊对对对谢宾主
Lucia: Ah, yeah, yeah, thanks.
Lucia: 看看他手机能不能接到
Lucia: Let's see if he can get a signal on his phone.
Lucia: 咋回事啊这些人
Lucia: What's up with these people?
Lucia: 奇怪
Lucia: Weird.
Katrina: 事情有点不对劲
Katrina: Something feels off.
Lucia: 对吧
Lucia: Right?
Katrina: 设置一点悬疑的点
Katrina: Adding a bit of suspense.
Katrina: 不又去那个彩票店了
Katrina: Not going to the lottery shop again.
Lucia: 不能吧他们不会被拐卖了吧
Lucia: No way, they wouldn't have been trafficked, right?
Lucia: 这么多个男生
Lucia: So many guys.
Lucia: 也不是随便能拐卖的了的吧
Lucia: They can't just be trafficked like that, right?
Lucia: 哎修硕又打回来了
Lucia: Hey, Shure's calling back.
Lucia: 在这干嘛呢
Lucia: What's he doing here?
Lucia: 哈喽哈喽
Lucia: Hello, hello.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Katrina: 他给我打过来
Katrina: He's calling me.
Lucia: 网络异常
Lucia: Network issue.
Lucia: 通话结束喂
Lucia: Call ended, hello?
Katrina: 喂
Katrina: Hello?
Lucia: 哈哈喂喂
Lucia: Haha, hello, hello.
Katrina: 喂你在哪呢
Katrina: Hello, where are you?
Lucia: 哎哎他们在那边
Lucia: Hey, hey, they're over there.
Lucia: 他们在那边
Lucia: They're over there.
Lucia: 哈哈啊
Lucia: Haha, ah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 刚才雨轩还说
Lucia: Just now Yuxuan was saying.
Lucia: 他们不会又去彩票店了吧哈哈
Lucia: They might have gone to the lottery shop again, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我刚接上你电话就网络异常又断了
Lucia: I just answered your call and then the network went down.
Shure: 为你不接
Shure: Why didn't you pick up?
Shure: 然后就给雨轩打
Shure: Then I called Yuxuan.
Shure: 看人家秒接你怎么回事
Shure: He answered right away, what's your problem?
Shure: 反思一下
Shure: Think about it.
Lucia: 这不是网络异常吗
Lucia: Wasn't it a network issue?
Shure: 这不网络异常吗
Shure: Wasn't it a network issue?
Shure: 那他的网络怎么不异常
Shure: Why isn't his network down?
Shure: 怎么全班就你一个人网络异常呢
Shure: Why is it that only you in the whole class have network issues?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 好味太冲了哈哈哈
Katrina: Such a strong flavor, hahaha.
Lucia: 那我们俩运营商不一样呗
Lucia: Maybe we have different service providers.
Shure: 那他怎么知道选那好的运营商
Shure: How did he know to pick the good one?
Shure: 你不知道呢
Shure: And you didn't?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 不是你挑我运营商毛病
Lucia: You're just criticizing my provider.
Lucia: 你怎么不去跟运营商对峙一下呢
Lucia: Why don't you confront the service provider?
Lucia: 是吧哈哈
Lucia: Right? Haha.
Lucia: 你让他你让他把这哈哈哈
Lucia: Ask them to improve their service.
Lucia: 你让他把这服务一改进一
Lucia: So I can always pick up your call instantly, right?
Lucia: 黑我这接你电话就秒接是吧
Lucia: Oh no, it's down again.
Lucia: 哎呦又掉啊
Lucia: It's dropped countless times today.
Lucia: 这玩意已经今天掉了无数次了
Lucia: Even though I've only had it for less than 10 minutes.
Lucia: 虽然从我拿上他到现在为止
Lucia: Since I got it until now.
Lucia: 还不超过10分钟
Lucia: It hasn't even been 10 minutes.
Shure: 没有共产党
Shure: Without the Communist Party... 政治问题
Katrina: 休叔帮我拿个这个呗
Katrina: Shure, can you get this for me?
Katrina: 因为它滑动摩擦力有点大
Katrina: Because it's got a bit of sliding friction.
Shure: （歌词）夏天夏天悄悄过去
Shure: (lyrics) Summer, summer quietly passes by...
Lucia: 这谁啊营销号
Lucia: Who is this, a marketing account?
Shure: （歌词）留下小秘密压心底
Shure: (lyrics) Leaving little secrets buried deep.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:咱也拿点吧
Jake: Let's grab some too.
Jake:给咱拿点
Jake: Get some for us.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 是
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 狐狸在哪啊
Lucia: Where's the fox?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh dear...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈这已经这样子出门了
Katrina: Hahaha, you're already going out like this.
其他人：这都已经急着拆开了
Others: It's already being opened in a rush.
Jake:这是围巾
Jake: This is a scarf.
Jake:这是围巾吗
Jake: Is this a scarf?
Katrina: 不是不是围巾要单独买
Katrina: No, no, the scarf has to be bought separately.
Lucia: 这是狐狸
Lucia: This is a fox.
Katrina: 围巾还没发货呢来不及
Katrina: The scarf hasn't shipped yet, it's too late.
Jake:这是个烟花吗
Jake: Is this a firework?
Jake:能买烟花吗
Jake: Can you buy fireworks?
其他人：毯子吧应该
Others: It's probably a blanket.
Jake:买烟花吧
Jake: Buy fireworks.
Jake:买烟花放烟花
Jake: Buy fireworks and set them off.
Katrina: 过年
Katrina: For New Year.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:你们那里给放烟花吧
Jake: Can you set off fireworks where you are?
Jake:我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Yes, we can.
Shure: 我们今年可以
Shure: We can do it this year.
Shure: 前几年都不行
Shure: We couldn't in previous years.
Jake:南洋理工不能放
Jake: Nanyang Tech can't.
Jake:军事的管制区
Jake: It's a military controlled area.
其他人:但我看之前嘴也不是会放仙女棒啊
Others: But I saw they used sparklers before.
Jake:仙女棒算什么东西
Jake: What's a sparkler?
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehe.
Lucia: 啊哪个组委会
Lucia: Which committee?
其他人:所以我好奇
Others: So I'm curious.
其他人:现在他有人陪了
Others: Does he have company now?
其他人:你们过年还会去
Others: Are you still going for New Year?
Jake:去啊去啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah, we are.
Jake:只有过年能见到他了
Jake: We can only see him during New Year.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
Jake:就是我老板
Jake: He's my boss.
Jake:就这个给钱的大老板
Jake: The big boss who pays us.
Jake:他这个谈恋爱之前天天跟我们吃饭
Jake: Before he started dating, he ate with us every day.
Jake:午饭和晚饭都够我们吃
Jake: Lunch and dinner, both covered.
Jake:谈恋爱之后就过年见着一次
Jake: After he started dating, we only see him during New Year.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈他多大年纪啊
Katrina: Haha, how old is he?
Shure: 怎么这个样子呢
Shure: How come it's like this?
其他人:所以他他不是刚谈吧
Other People: So he didn't just start dating, right?
Jake:没有他他女朋友从美国回来了对
Jake: No, his girlfriend came back from America.
其他人:居然是America
Other People: From America, really?
其他人：所以他女朋友是我们这个领域的吗
Other People: So is his girlfriend in our field?
Jake:不算是思科
Jake: Not really, she's at Cisco.
Shure: Cisco这段说实话
Shure: Cisco, to be honest...
Jake:cisco
Jake: Cisco.
其他人：哈哈哈非常的形象
Other People: Hahaha, that's a great analogy.
其他人：这段怎么说
Other People: How do you say this part?
Katrina: 你好有职业素养哈哈哈
Katrina: You are so professional, hahaha.
其他人:嗯可以不记这段
Other People: Hmm, maybe we don't need to include this part.
Shure: Cisco不能叫吧
Shure: Cisco can't be called American Huawei, right?
Jake:美国那怎么说
Jake: How should we say it then?
Shure: 他应该叫
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:这也太要紧了
Jake: That's way too much.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈不行吗
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha, is that not okay?
Shure: 他不如华为啊
Shure: It's not as good as Huawei.
Shure: 不行吗行
Shure: Is it not okay? It's fine.
Jake:行没问题没问题
Jake: It's fine, no problem.
Jake:硬件设备
Jake: Hardware equipment.
其他人:硬件设备供应商吗
Other People: Hardware equipment supplier?
Jake:你华为做什么了
Jake: What does Huawei do?
Jake:他不做手机
Jake: They don't make phones.
Jake:除了别的
Jake: Besides other things.
其他人：华为华为
Other People: Huawei, Huawei.
Jake:我靠那什么东西啊我靠
Jake: Damn, what the heck?
Shure: 哈哈哈越来越不能播
Shure: Hahaha, this is getting more and more unbroadcastable.
Jake:行我们换个话题好吧
Jake: Okay, let's change the topic.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehehe.
其他人:所以所以他
Other People: So, so...
其他人:他女朋友回来就要定居在新加坡了
Other People: His girlfriend is going to settle in Singapore?
Shure: 呀
Shure: Wow.
Jake:是吧哎呀
Jake: Right? Oh my.
Shure: 哎呀我今天晚上7点有个会啊
Shure: Oh no, I have a meeting at 7 PM tonight.
其他人:牛逼还好
Other People: Awesome, just in time.
其他人:像我会一般都安排到晚上10点半之后
Others: People like me usually schedule it after 10:30 PM.
其他人:可是我不会忘了
Others: But I won't forget.
Jake:啊你还要挣扎吗
Jake: Ah, are you still struggling?
Jake:他7点的会还要挣扎吗
Jake: Are you still struggling with the 7 PM meeting?
Jake:也不用了吧
Jake: You don't need to, right?
Lucia: 这不都7:46了吗
Lucia: Isn't it already 7:46?
Jake:对啊你还要挣扎吗
Jake: Yeah, are you still struggling?
Shure: 我是主持人
Shure: I'm the host.
Shure: 我是社长啊哈哈哈
Shure: I'm the president, haha.
Jake:哦有人找你是吧
Jake: Oh, someone is looking for you, right?
Lucia: 那完了大家已经等了你46分钟了
Lucia: Then it's over, everyone's been waiting for you for 46 minutes.
Jake:你说你你取快递
Jake: You said you went to pick up a package.
Katrina: 你耍大牌呀
Katrina: You're acting like a big shot.
Jake:取快递取46分钟没问题
Jake: Taking 46 minutes to pick up a package is no problem.
Katrina: 直接46分钟
Katrina: A whole 46 minutes.
Shure: 我刚才公司给我突然来了个电话
Shure: My company suddenly called me just now.
Katrina: 往哪走
Katrina: Where are you going?
Jake:对对都能走都能走
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you can go anywhere.
Jake:换条新路
Jake: Take a new route.
Shure: 刚lida突然
Shure: Just now, Lida suddenly...
Shure: 给我派了个活
Shure: Gave me a task.
Shure: 我一下忙忙忙忘了
Shure: I got busy and forgot.
Lucia: 走着
Lucia: Keep walking.
Lucia: 啥啊
Lucia: What?
Katrina: 他说丽德给他派活了
Katrina: He said Lida gave him a task.
Katrina: 他忙忘了
Katrina: He got busy and forgot.
Jake:嗯嗯确实
Jake: Yeah, yeah, indeed.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: Indeed.
Katrina: 确实是啊
Katrina: Indeed, right.
Katrina: 丽的让你
Katrina: Lida asked you...
Katrina: 出来取快递
Katrina: To go pick up a package.
其他人:你这样说你就说啊
Others: If you say so, just say it.
其他人:刚才丽特给我呃安排了一下
Others: Just now, Lida arranged something for me.
其他人:明天我们要上线一个party
Others: Tomorrow we're launching a party.
其他人:刚刚和同事们对齐了一下
Others: I just coordinated with my colleagues.
其他人:所以搞的比较晚
Others: So it got a bit late.
其他人:什么行业
Others: What industry?
其他人:黑花
Others: Black flowers.
Jake:呵你要说特殊情况
Jake: Heh, you should mention special circumstances.
Jake:见着个狐狸
Jake: Met a fox.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈抓狐狸去了哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, went to catch a fox, hahaha.
Shure: 好拽你这个
Shure: That's so cool of you.
Jake:对对有点不巧
Jake: Yeah, it was a bit unlucky.
Lucia: 好冷啊我天
Lucia: It's so cold, oh my god.
Jake:哎呦阿丽丽
Jake: Oh, hey Alice.
Lucia: 希望这几玩意拆开颜色没有色差
Lucia: I hope the colors of these things match when we unpack them.
Lucia: 要不然我就系了哈
Lucia: Otherwise, I'll be so mad.
Jake:晚上咱现在就在开始弄
Jake: We'll start working on it tonight.
其他人:那那晚上一般几点钟弄完
Others: So, what time do we usually finish at night?
Jake:这个很难讲
Jake: It's hard to say.
其他人:还有一场吗
Others: Is there another session?
Jake:今晚没了
Jake: Not tonight.
Jake:今晚就收拾收拾嘛
Jake: Tonight, we'll just tidy up.
Jake:拆拆快递嘛
Jake: Unpack some deliveries.
Jake:随便拍拍嘛
Jake: Take some casual shots.
其他人:那我约 10点半
Others: Then I'll schedule it for 10:30.
Jake:你可以约
Jake: You can schedule it.
Jake:你随便什么时候约
Jake: Schedule it whenever you want.
其他人：游戏的 10点
Others: The game at 10?
其他人：半我不知道
Others: I don't know about half past.
其他人：我在思考
Others: I'm thinking.
其他人:是啊他爷爷不就说嘛
Others: Yeah, his grandpa said it.
其他人:孩子长大了
Others: The kid has grown up.
其他人:等他回到家那个
Others: When he gets home...
其他人:跟他回去
Others: Go back with him.
Katrina: 这还挺漂亮
Katrina: This is quite pretty.
其他人:台球啊哈哈
Others: Billiards, hahaha.
其他人：我会我的台球是
Others: I know my billiards...
其他人：因为输了要付钱
Others: Because you have to pay if you lose.
Shure: 我可以
Shure: I can do it.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 我帮你整治
Shure: I can fix it for you.
Jake:啊工作不饱和啊
Jake: Ah, the work is not saturated.
Shure: 刘帅好吧
Shure: Choiszt, alright.
Jake:工作不饱和
Jake: The work is not saturated.
Jake:看着
Jake: Look.
其他人:什么叫工作不饱和
Others: What do you mean the work is not saturated?
Lucia: 还有时间打台球
Lucia: Still have time to play billiards.
其他人:啊昨天已经过饱和了
Others: Ah, yesterday it was already oversaturated.
其他人:好嘞你知道我整个人都快要结晶了
Others: Alright, you know, I'm almost crystallized.
Lucia: 结晶了哈哈哈
Lucia: Crystallized, hahaha.
Jake:呵呵你这是怎么讲
Jake: Haha, what do you mean?
Jake:脱水了是吗
Jake: Dehydrated, right?
其他人：踏进云川的门
Others: Stepping into Yun Chuan's door.
其他人：给我递热毛巾那个是那啥的
Others: Hand me a hot towel, that’s what.
Shure: 那个是那什么
Shure: That’s what?
其他人：台球海底捞
Others: Pool table hot pot.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
其他人：台球海底捞
Others: Pool table hot pot.
其他人：嗯台
Others: Hmm, pool.
其他人：对台球海底捞
Others: Right, pool table hot pot.
其他人：给你递水果递饮料递茶啊
Others: They serve you fruits, drinks, tea.
其他人:这么牛逼啊
Others: That’s so amazing.
Lucia: 多牛逼啊
Lucia: So amazing.
Jake:多少钱多少钱
Jake: How much does it cost?
其他人:也不贵不贵
Others: Not expensive at all.
其他人:就是正常价
Others: Just a normal price.
Jake:哎我们要拐了
Jake: Hey, we have to turn.
其他人:那这种台阶
Others: This kind of steps.
Lucia: 在这拐
Lucia: Turn here.
其他人:都不会把别人杀的毫无还手之力
Others: Won't kill anyone without a fight.
其他人:哎这边这边不往前走两下都行
Others: Hey, this way, this way, it's okay to walk forward a bit.
Lucia: 还是停一下
Lucia: Let's stop for a moment.
其他人:都行吗要不就晚了
Others: Is it okay? Or it'll be too late.
其他人：那不就往往这边这边拐
Others: Then turn this way.
Jake:这边拐可以啊
Jake: Turning here is fine.
Jake:那就这么拐吧
Jake: Let's turn this way.
其他人:百球小生会观察你
Others: The billiard pro will watch you.
其他人:你要是这一球要用上加盖了
Others: If you need to use the cover for this shot.
其他人:他主动帮你把加盖抬起来
Others: He'll lift the cover for you.
其他人:我双手递给你
Others: Hand it to you with both hands.
其他人:那加盖用完了
Others: When the cover's done.
其他人:那双手递回来
Others: He'll hand it back with both hands.
其他人:那别的排气
Others: What about other vents?
其他人:那别的排球生存空间在哪呢
Others: What about other billiard players' living space?
其他人:我不知道啊
Others: I don't know.
其他人:我以后肯定只去银川
Others: From now on, I’ll only go to Yin Chuan.
其他人:太逆天了
Others: It's too awesome.
其他人:对于一个小城市出来的我
Others: For someone coming from a small town.
其他人:我去哈哈哈
Others: Oh my god, hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Shure: 他那特贵
Shure: He's so expensive
其他人:留下一部位
Others: Reserve a spot
其他人:留下金爷就比较会享受啊
Others: Leave it to King, he knows how to enjoy life
其他人:他说下次
Others: He said next time
Shure: 79一小时
Shure: 79 per hour
其他人:他说下次带我去个更好的地方
Others: He said next time he'll take me to a better place
其他人:哦不是你可以美谈美观啊
Others: Oh, you can talk about aesthetics
其他人:确实今天要坐一下刘帅
Others: Indeed, today we should sit with Choiszt
其他人:让我让我看看刘帅开奔驰是什么样子
Others: Let me see what it's like for Choiszt to drive a Benz
其他人:但是开奔驰的人会不会变帅
Others: But does driving a Benz make you handsome?
其他人:我靠他那个后排的空间巨大
Others: Wow, the space in the back is huge
Shure: 真就是给老板坐的巨爽
Shure: It's really made for the boss, super comfortable
Shure: 而且你后排是可以瞧前排座椅的
Shure: And you can even see the front seats from the back
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, okay
其他人:非常的人性化
Others: Very user-friendly
Shure: 不会像那个捷达你连找找都找不着
Shure: Unlike a Jetta, where you can't find anything
其他人:我的手就是找条达到胳膊
Others: My hand is just reaching around blindly
Shure: 一看就没开过
Shure: Clearly never driven one
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Shure: 少爷就是没开过这种手动咔咔咔的车
Shure: The young master has never driven a manual car like this
Shure: 哎太金贵了少爷
Shure: He's too precious
其他人：他奔驰手动是肯定是
Others: A Benz manual is definitely something
其他人：如果没有学法减分我马上就要回去学手动挡车了
Others: If there were no point reductions, I'd go learn manual driving right away
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 好冷啊
Lucia: It's so cold
Lucia: 这灯的配色也太
Lucia: The color scheme of this light is just too...
Jake:撞色
Jake: Contrasting
Lucia: 也行吧
Lucia: Well, it works
Jake:哈哈独特的设计
Jake: Haha, unique design
Jake:给他唱一段
Jake: Sing a bit for him
Jake:不像
Jake: Doesn't seem like it
Lucia: 轰趴
Lucia: Party
其他人:喝酒喝吐了
Others: Drank until he puked
其他人:只喝一分钟
Others: Only drank for a minute
其他人:学英语交流
Others: Learning English communication
Lucia: 那只要沉默1分钟就好了
Lucia: Then just be silent for a minute
Shure: 这就是京爷的生活
Shure: This is King’s life
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Shure: 香椿天妇罗
Shure: Toona tempura
Shure: 我天
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 哎sorry sorry
Shure: Oh sorry, sorry
Shure: 一般那粥都得自己加
Shure: Usually, you have to add it yourself
Shure: 北方这边默认都不加什么糖什么东西
Shure: In the north, we usually don't add sugar or anything
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then
Shure: 所以小时候就特不爱喝这种粥啥的
Shure: So I didn't like drinking that kind of porridge as a kid
Jake:北极能看到星星
Jake: You can see stars in the Arctic
Shure: 通州沙河都能看到星星
Shure: You can see stars in Tongzhou and Shahe too
Jake:哦不是北京是吧
Jake: Oh, not in Beijing, right?
Shure: 哎能能能
Shure: Yeah, yeah, you can
Shure: 不不这算
Shure: No, no, it counts
Shure: 北京这这场地也记一下
Shure: Beijing, mark this location too
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 他试图分裂北京
Shure: He's trying to split Beijing
Jake:这哈哈哈
Jake: This, hahaha
Jake:就你这个迹象哈哈哈
Jake: Just this sign, hahaha
Shure: 然后我小时吃这种
Shure: And then when I was a kid, I ate this
Jake:梅开二度
Jake: Scored twice
Shure: 然后加了还不让加
Shure: And adding it wasn't allowed
Shure: 就是我们家基本什么东西都不让加
Shure: Basically, in my family, we weren't allowed to add anything
Lucia: 什么你是说我这个东西掉下来吗
Lucia: What, you mean this thing fell?
Jake:给一个给一个
Jake: Give one, give one
Jake:谢谢没有没有
Jake: Thanks, no, no
Jake:说他
Jake:美开2路
Jake: Scored twice on Road 2
Jake:美开3路
Jake: Scored thrice on Road 3
Jake:帽子戏法了
Jake: Hat trick
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 帽子戏法
Lucia: Hat trick
Lucia: 不是加个小
Lucia: Not adding a small
Lucia: 不应该能
Lucia: Shouldn't it be
Jake:哈哈哈炸死你
Jake: Hahaha, blow you up
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Jake:哈哈喷他去
Jake: Hahaha, spray him
Shure: 可是我的伤悲胜过了一些
Shure: But my sadness surpasses some of it
Lucia: 又有一只小猫
Lucia: There's another kitten
Shure: 往哪走来着
Shure: Where are we headed again?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Mm, mm, mm.
Jake:都行呵呵呵
Jake: Anything's fine, haha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Jake:走走了造吧哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's do it, haha.
Shure: 实话简直难以置信哈哈
Shure: Honestly, it's just unbelievable, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈难以置信
Lucia: Haha, unbelievable.
Lucia: 哈哈哈总能到吧
Lucia: Haha, we can always get there, right?
Jake:总能总能到吧
Jake: We can always get there, right?
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Lucia: 哈哈啊
Lucia: Haha, ah.
其他人:哎那边
Others: Hey, over there!
Jake:那边哎
Jake: Over there, hey.
Jake:回来了哈哈哈
Jake: We're back, hahaha.
Jake:不太行了
Jake: Not really working out.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Narrow escape.
Lucia: 那个50
Lucia: That 50.
Shure: 这脑子呀
Shure: This brain, oh.
Shure: 我天呐一天啥事都记不住
Shure: Oh my, can't remember anything all day.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Shure: 我就昨天应该加提醒时让再加个闹钟
Shure: I should have added a reminder, set another alarm.
Katrina: 定闹钟我现在干啥事都定闹钟
Katrina: Setting an alarm, I set one for everything now.
Lucia: 看看我们现在到哪
Lucia: Let's see where we are now.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 呃对是的
Lucia: Uh, yes, right.
Shure: 哎呦喂真服了
Shure: Oh boy, I'm really impressed.
Lucia: that's it
Lucia: That's it.
Shure: 哎我天呐
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 脑子呀脑子啊
Shure: Brain, oh brain.
Katrina: 我的隐形眼镜终于可以
Katrina: Finally, my contact lenses.
Shure: 快长脑子吧
Shure: Hurry up and grow a brain.
Jake:我去好香啊
Jake: Wow, it smells so good.
Lucia: 哎呀可以先放在这感觉一会再拆啊
Lucia: Oh, we can leave it here for now and unpack it later.
Lucia: 累了累了累了累了
Lucia: Tired, tired, tired.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:确实来给你们吃
Jake: Really, here, have some.
Jake:快递
Jake: Delivery.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina: 好香啊
Katrina: Smells so good.
Jake:什么货哦
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 好香啊
Lucia: Smells so good.
Katrina: 我终于可以戴眼镜了
Katrina: I can finally wear glasses.
Lucia: 我洗洗手
Lucia: I'll wash my hands.
Jake:吃吃汉堡吃蛋挞
Jake: Eat burgers, eat egg tarts.
Jake:吃什么呀
Jake: What should we eat?
Jake:蛋挞是吧
Jake: Egg tarts, right?
Jake:好有什么好的吗
Jake: Okay, anything good?
Shure: 帅帅师傅
Shure: Master Shuai.
Jake:有有有好的甜品吗
Jake: Are there any good desserts?
其他人:如果没有人点的就是我点的
Others: If nobody ordered it, then I did.
其他人:但是我忘了你点的
Others: But I forgot what you ordered.
Lucia: okay okay
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 一只neck
Lucia: A neck.
Lucia: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Jake:严谨严谨
Jake: Be precise, be precise.
Jake:吃点什么呢
Jake: What should we eat?
Lucia: 哪个是我的来着
Lucia: Which one is mine?
Lucia: 我又忘了
Lucia: I forgot again.
Jake:没关系盲盒麦当劳盲盒
Jake: It's okay, blind box McDonald's.
Lucia: 麦当劳盲盒
Lucia: McDonald's blind box.
Jake:对麦当劳盲盒
Jake: Yeah, McDonald's blind box.
Jake:因为路就很远
Jake: Because the road is very far.
Alice:走路去的吗
Alice: Did you walk there?
Lucia: 这个好像是牛奶
Lucia: This seems like milk.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 是吗
Lucia: Really?
Lucia: 哪个是哪个是
Lucia: Which one, which one?
Lucia: 好巧克力
Lucia: Okay, chocolate.
Lucia: 那这个应该是热巧克力吧
Lucia: Then this should be hot chocolate, right?
Alice:饮品在这里
Alice: The drinks are here.